نتحدث عن اختيار صعب لغزا محير تجد المراه
نفسها امامه بل وستكون مسؤوله لوحدها عن
نتيجه قرارها نتحدث عن اختيار بين طموح
العمل من جهه وبين الزواج وبناء اسره
والتفرغ لاهتمام بها هو صعب لكثير من
النساء دراسات سابقه اشارت الى ان خروج
المراه للعمل كان من الاسباب الرئيسيه
لارتفاع نسبه الطلاق في الوطن العربي لكن
يبدو انها مفاضله تقع فيها كل نساء العالم
ولا تقتصر على مجتمعاتنا فقط بل ان كافه
الزواج والاسره ترجع عند اكثر من نصف نساء
العالم الى كافه الطموح
بتابع المزيد في التقرير التاريخ
قد يظن البعض ان التضارب الازلي لدى
الفتيات بين الطموح المهني وحلمي تاسيس
اسره
يقتصروا على العالم العربي والمجتمعات
المحافظه لكن التضارب ورغم كل مظاهر
التقدم هو في الواقع ازمه نسائيه عالميه
دراسه امريكيه اظهرت ان اكثر من 60 بالمئه
من النساء حول العالم يتخلين بدرجه من
الدرجات عن الطموح المهني لاجل الزواج
وتكوين اسره الرقم البارز هو 19% من
النساء لا يكترثن اصلا للموضوع المهني لا
طموح لديهن في هذا المجال اما اللواتي
يعطينا الاولويه للطموح المهني فهي بنسبه
مماثله تقريبا 20%
ورغم كل التقدم في الانماط الاجتماعيه بما
في ذلك في الغرب ما زالت طموح المهني
وتحقيق النجاح في الوظيفه يكلف المراه
الكثير وذلك بحسب جامعه كامريجا
البريطانيه وكالعاده حياه المراه صعبه
ويتعين عليها ان تحدد اولوياتها واذا
اختارت الوظيفه فهذا لا يعفيها ابدا من
مهامها العائليه
لصباح العربيه الريان الظاهر
من القاهره تنضمي الينا سيده العمال شيرين
شكري شيرين يسعد صباحك اهلا بك شكرا على
تواجدك معانا هذه الفقره ما بين الطموح
المهني والطموح العمل وما بين الزواج الى
اي منهما تميل كفه شيرين ولماذا
[موسيقى]
طيب كفت شيرين تميل الى الطموح العملي
مش علشان اي سبب لكن لانه هي الحياه
اولويات في حد بيقرر انه اولوياتي تكون
لبيتي او لزوجي وفي احد ثاني بيقرر انه
اولوياتي تكون لنجاح المهنيين
وانا باشوف انه دائما الاولويات لازم تكون
للنجاح المهني
وانطلاقه الزواج او انطلاقه الارتباط او
العلاقه تكون ماشيه مع بعض ما ينفعش ده
ينفصل عندها شيرين لكن زي ما كان بتقول
فلتقير نعم يعني عم بتقولي انه الحياه
عندما تكون في العمل فالعمل اولويه عندما
تكون في البيت في البيت الاولويه
هاقول لك ببساطه لانه انا شخص واحد فما
ينفعش يبقى عندي الوقت كل وقت ليه اولويه
مختلفه هو اولويات حياه انا برتب اولويات
حياتي لو انا عندي اولويه لبيتي في او
لزواجي فانا هكرر ان انا اتزوج واجيب
اولاد لو اولوياتي العمليها قرر ان انا
اشتغل واحقق طموحي طيب شيرين في بعض
النساء يعني اثبتنا تجربه ناجحه جدا في
التوازن بين
الطموح المهني وما بين الزواج يعني النساء
متزوجات سيدات اعمال ناجحات وهن متزوجات
ولديهن اولادهم كذلك نساء في مجال السياسه
ومجال الاعلام وما الى ذلك لماذا لا يتحقق
توازن
ممكن يتحقق التوازن لكن ده صعب جدا
وهتلاقي الحالات اللي حضرتك بتقولي عليها
حالات استثنائيه يعني بنسبه بسيطه جدا لكن
دائما بتكون اولويه الست بالجريزه ان هي
تبقى ام فطبيعي لو اتحط الخيار بين
الامومه وبين الحياه العمليه هتختار
الامومه عشان كده الجواز احنا بنقول انه
مش بس بيقتل الطموح او بيعطل الطموح لكنه
بيخلي انه ما فيش وقت للطموح دائما
اولوياتي في الوقت لاولادي
الامومه ايضا تعني المسؤوليه وقد تكوني
ايضا مسؤوله في بيتك وفي عملك وفي حياتك
بالتالي اعرف كثيرا من النساء هم يريدون
ان يصبحوا اكثر نجاحا في عملي انه بسبب في
بيته لنا وبسبب اولادهننا وحتى يظلوا كبار
في عيوني ازواجهن ايضا
تمام هي هتنجح بس هل هتنجح بالنسبه لكافيه
اللي هي كانت بتحلم بيها الطموح اللي هي
كانت راسمهال نفسها وهي لسه بنت او هي لسه
نفسها تحقق ذاتها ولا لا طيب
بالحديقه يعني اسلوب الحياه المعاصر يا
شيرين بكل واقعيه منطقيه نتحدث يعني بيت
الام يعني الام في البيت ما تمسك اولادها
24 ساعه بحضنها يعني فيها قاعده معاهم في
البيت وهي عم تدير اعمالها حتى من
الموبايل او من اللابتوب يعني اون لاين ما
رايك بذلك يعني فيها تكون ناجحه حتى في
البيت
طبعا فيها تكون ناجحه بس هل نسبه تركيزها
في عملها هتكون بنسبه 100% ولا هتكون
بنسبه 30% و 70% للطفل اللي في ايدي او
لبيتي او ل ااا
متطلبات الزواج او متطلبات الحياه العمليه
او مسؤوليتي البيت
لماذا ربطتي دائما الطموح في العمل هناك
تعريف مختلف للطموح كل حسب مفهومه يعني في
نساء تعتبر بان اقصى طموحنا هي الزواج
وتربيه اسره صالحه وابناء صالحين في بيتهم
بتعتبر حالها عملت انجاز
علشان كده زي ما قلت لك في اول الكلام هي
الحياه اختيارات كل حد قدامه كل
الاختيارات لكن مش بسهوله اقتنع او اصدق
ان انا ينفع احقق 100% في كل الاختيارات
طيب
مفيش حاجه اسمها مئه في المئه في البيت
عن طموح في سبيل الزواج
[موسيقى]
اكيد انه ما بتخلى عنه يعني الواحد اذا ما
اشتغل وما كان حاله اكيد يعني لانه الزواج
هو بينها طموح البني ادم يعني شيء اكيد
[موسيقى]
ومش انا اتخلى يعني بس انه ممكن الزواج
كان نفسي اكمل يعني واعمل مشاريع خاصه في
انا قد خليت عنها واجلتها لحد ما اولادي
كبروا
[موسيقى]
طيب شيرين ما رايك بمن قال انه يؤجل طموحه
لما بعد يكبر اولاده او انه يختار مهنه
يعني لا تضر بوقته في البيت
[موسيقى]
طب هو عمري في كم سنه
في احنا بنضل عايشين لكل العمر نعمل ونقضي
ونحقق طموحنا ما في حتى طموح ما الهمر
[موسيقى]
ربنا يدي الناس كلها الصحه والعمر لكن
العمر ده والصحه دي هتيجي في وقت بعد ما
تكوني تستنزفي طاقتك في ان انت بتربي
اطفال
صعب قوي ان يبقى عندك لسه طاقه انك تكملي
وتشتغلي وتحققي طموحك شيرين لو كنت تزوجتي
كنتي بنفس الكلام
ونفس الموقف
بمنتهى الامانه لو كنت تزوجت ما اعتقدش ان
انا كنت هكون في المكان اللي انا فيها
النهارده لان انا النهارده قادره اخذ
مخاطر لو انا متزوجه كان هيبقى اسهل
اختيار ليا ان انا اسيب المخاطر واسيب
الشغل واركز في بيتي طب كيف
رائده اعمال وسيده اعمال وهم بنفس مستواكي
من النجاح ولكن متزوجات شو رايك
هتلاقي في شويه اختلافات بمعنى هتلاقيها
مثلا اكبر مني شويه في السن هتلاقي دائما
خذها للمخاطر محدود هي مش قادره تكون
مخاطره للدرجه هتلاقي قدرتها على الابداع
مختلفه لانه ده طبيعي هي ابداعها كله
وتركيزها كله رايح في النهايه تربي
اولادها شيرين اكثر ما ورايح انها تبدا في
شغلها نعم اعرف كثيره اعرف كثيرا من
زميلات الصحفيات متزوجات
ولديهم اولاد ويذهبوا الى اماكن خطره حول
العالم
[موسيقى]
ميدانيه لحروق وكانوا في قلب الميدان وهم
ما اجمل منهم الميدان وما اجمل منهم ايضا
كثيرا منهم انا مش باقول لك ان هي فئه
معدومه لكن مش فئه سايبه هتلاقي دول كميه
او عدد محدود مش الطبيعي
طيب شيرين شكرا جزيلا لك يبقى هذا رايك يا
شيرين
شكرا اتمنى لك دوم النجاح يا شيرين شكرا
جزيلا لك